Carter Evans was in the middle of things
outside the rally last night when police
used tear gas and pepper spray to force
away protesters Carter good morning good
morning this is where thousands of
protesters and Trump supporters were
gathered before the rally they were very
vocal but largely peaceful all of that
changed however after the president
spoke and a small group of protesters
ignored police orders to leave it was
chaos in confusion outside the Phoenix
Convention Center Tuesday night police
used tear gas to clear the streets of
largely anti-trump protesters after the
president's rally you can see the police
here in their riot here you can see the
smoke they've been setting off flashbang
grenades to try and disperse the crowd
this protester we seen kicking a smoke
bomb tour police who responded by
shooting him with a non-lethal
projectile police made five arrests at
least two of them for criminal assault
on an officer
before the rally the thousands of Trump
supporters entering the Convention
Center were met by a wall of protesters
the hilar family says the level of
animosity surprised them we stand for
what we believe in and they stand for
what they believe in which is America at
its best at its finest so I'm proud of
that
police set of barriers to keep the two
sides apart but many of the thousands
they're opposing Trump in his policies
say they felt their voices were heard we
have a united front people from all over
not just immigrant rights that are
coming together the mayor says there
will be an investigation into what led
to the confrontation between protesters
and police the chief says that no rubber
bullets were used and there were no
reported injuries except to police
officers who were treated for heat
exhaustion Norah all right Carter thank
you very much